mein name ist luca meine lieben freunde
ich darf euch heute recht herzlich
willkommen heißen zu einem video auf das
ich mich schon länger freude denn wir
spielen heute gemeinsam den power
watching you later wir müssen nicht als
allerersten job einen transporter
reinigen von hektik ich mal direkt auf
job starten und ihr fragt euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich luca warum freust du dich
auf dieses video so kratz ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich liebe es
die djs hört sich jetzt zwar dumm an
allerdings liebe ich es sachen zu
reinigen sachen sauber zu machen und ich
finde es richtig zäh deswegen
[Musik]
mache ich damit jetzt den lack ab und
schaut euch mal an wie geil das aussieht
wir können hier theoretisch einfach was
in die seite reinschreiben was
steht
heute soll es allerdings nicht um das
beste merchandise einen ganz youtube
deutschland gehen in lumino shop.de
sondern um diesen watch simulator meiner
lieben freunde und ich bekomme mal
direkt wieder zurück auf das thema was
ich zu beginn angesprochen habe ich
liebe es einfach sachen zu reinigen weil
ich weiss ja immer so eine dumme clowns
musik hintergrund spiel das aber hört
euch das mal so an
[Musik]
es ist in einer gewissen form wie es mr
so richtig beruhigen können wir das
ganze jahr zum saubermachen und richtig
hier mit nummer musik und keine ahnung
was aber das wollen wir nicht
wir wollen die karre ganz normal
reinigen
ich finde das so entspannend
er hört schon hier ist ab und zu immer
was am klimpern deswegen nämlich daran
dass wir hier wirklich aufgaben haben
zum beispiel wenn ich das hier vorne
jetzt auffällig haben wir jetzt auch
wieder klimpern
hier vielleicht wenn ich das hier durch
habe
es geht doch nicht richtig sauber hier
ne
a doch wir sehen auch oben links bzw nur
so wenn ich euch mal ganz gut meine
facetime ausblende wir haben 48 prozent
schon fertig gereinigt ich weiß nicht ob
man einen transporter wirklich so
reinigen sollte wie ich das hier gerade
mache mit der vorgehensweise nämlich
nämlich auf dem dach rumlaufe aber es
ist wirklich komplett ist wenn man hier
einfach mal so perfekt vorgeht einfach
mal so hier in lion und dann hier vorne
noch ne leihen und dann das ganze
erinnere mich auch so ein bisschen an
diesen lohn morning simulator den ich ja
auch letztens hochgeladen habe das sind
zwei videos und ich weiß auch dass
dieses video ihr euch so krass
zwischendecke geben wird wie
beispielsweise wenn ich stimmt jetzt
auch nicht lachen challenges video dings
reagiert hätte aber solche videos
vor dem haus meiner albtraum nachbarn
steht ein umzugswagen endlich ziehen sie
aus wer dort einzieht wird einen guten
hochdruckreiniger brauchen habe ich
direkt die nächste aufgabe bekommen was
ich gerade sagen wollte war dass das
hier solche videos sind die mir einfach
extrem viel spaß machen es ist mag der
ein oder andere gerade vielleicht glaube
ich nicht glauben aber diese videos hier
die finde ich wirklich zu entspannen und
einfach sowas zu mähen oder sauber
machen warum kirche keine shipment
das dach ist doch selber kümmern wir uns
jetzt allerdings erstmal noch um die
rückfenster hier vorne hinten die sind
nämlich immer so ein bisschen
schwieriger sauber zu kriegen sagte aber
die eine seite fertig hier gehen wir
dann jetzt mal ein bisschen flexibler
vor nicht flexibler ein bisschen wie
nennt man das ein bisschen
ich kann gut reinigen habe ich kann mama
ja
ich mache mein auto sauber
[Musik]
nähe selber
ja kannst du auch an einem sonntag
machen
mama ich spielen spiel in dem meine
nachbarn bild nach ich möchte mich
danach ok
und
luca du kannst doch nicht an einem
sonntag den autor selber sauber machen
die arme nach
vorne oben nochmal alles sauber machen
und jetzt hier unten lang wisst ihr was
leute ich glaube ich werde euch eine
ganz fixe time lab seien aber mit seiner
schönen
entspannten yoga meditationsmusik
[Musik]
so meine damen und herren wir sehen
links an der seite dass wir zu erledigen
haben nur noch einen reifen ich glaube
da geht es hier um den letzten genau job
abgeschlossen wir haben zusätzliche
reinigungsmittel verfügbar und können
zum fortfahren und einfach jetzt unser
tablet öffnen das hier sind wir
ich glaube so geht man auch
vor beim
reinigen wir haben auf jeden fall
geschafft weiter geht's meine lieben
freunde garten reinigen wir müssen den
garten glaub ich von unseren nachbarn
nun reinigen da kam mir gerade eine
kleine meldung rein der ist extrem
um ein gottes ist alles dreckig
hier
das auch
wir haben hier auf jeden fall einiges zu
tun starten wir einfach mal hier vorne
mit dem gartenhäuschen die tür haben wir
davon auf jeden fall schon erledigt die
vorderseite ist auch schon ziemlich
sauber das sind alles einzeln ich hilfe
wenn sie wegen kriegen mit dem
glockenspiel was er dann irgendwie jetzt
auch noch sauber kriegen hier vorne wenn
wir uns ans fenster machen ich habe erst
ich habe zwei prozent steht oben links
wo wohnen die hier überhaupt
könne ausbrechen
nee
das ist ja eine heidenarbeit hier immer
nur uns als nächstes jahr einfach mal
kurz um diesen kleinen mini hier dafür
können wir auch einfach mal zack und
zwei stockwerke hier runter bewegen und
den mini hier einfach mal so ein
bisschen sauer machen mein erstes auto
war ein mini auch sogar von mini cabrio
da sagt quasi nicht genauso aus wie der
hier nur ein bisschen größeren einsätzen
konnte die rückseite haben wir fertig
generell haben die mini eigentlich
fertig nur noch hier oben rein ist halt
blöd weil da drin sondern sitzt und die
machen wir wollen das aber irgendwie
bekommen wir nicht dass ich tief meint
spielzeugauto gar einig wir haben 157
dollar
damit könnte man sich drei rudis kaufen
als nächstes kümmern wir uns hier mal
ums vogelhäuschen das sollte glaube ich
relativ fix gehen hier den ständer haben
wir erledigt ich weiß ja wirklich uns
herum jeder seite kümmern müssen
allerdings kommen wir da auch easy run
hier ich weiß noch gar nicht ob wir
genügend wasser dabei haben weil ich das
ja immer die ganze zeit laufen so sollte
man wahrscheinlich auch nicht vorgehen
allerdings kommt es wahrscheinlich dann
auch aufs level und auch auf die
schwierigkeit an und wenn man das
hinkriegt oder nicht muss ich auch so
richtig drunter gehen ich weiß gar nicht
es ist schon krasser als erwartet dieses
spiel also als ich mir das im internet
angeguckt hatte das ist so ja auch kommt
einfach ein bisschen reinigen
als recht schwierig weil man hier ein
für die vögel
[Musik]
ich bin doch durch oder nicht
hier
[Musik]
sorry aber das ist ein vogelhäuschen h
das ist jetzt
und ich hab insgesamt erst hier
erledigt also ich muss schon sagen das
spielt jetzt wirklich sehr selbst
hättest feiern also gerade wenn man auf
so sachen steht wie reinigen und blabla
ich selbst bin zum beispiel ein sehr
sehr sehr sehr ordentlicher mensch
könnte mir auch mal auch in die
kommentare schreiben ob er so leute seid
jetzt irgendwie im chaos leben können
meine schwester zum beispiel hatte
früher immer so ein schild an ihrer
eingangstür unnormal krems wo einfach
irgendwie drauf stand
ein genie lebt nicht in der ordnung
sondern beherrscht das chaos
komisch ich würde sagen das letzte
projekt für heutige video wird dieser
hundehütte hier seien damit zumindest
der hund sich ein bisschen wohl fühlt da
gehen wir jetzt einfach mal so vor dass
wir uns von oben nach unten herab
arbeiten erstmal hier das dach so ein
bisschen fertigbau dann müssen wir auch
einmal beim vogelhäuser gelernt und
wirklich auch hinlegen um die pikanten
richtig mitzunehmen und genau das reicht
wenn man hier auf der anderen seite zack
einmal und hier noch einmal zurück da
natürlich hier drunter noch mal kurz
herr blasen und dann von oben drauf dann
aber das dach auf jeden fall an der
stelle schon mal fertig jetzt geht es
hier um die rückseite und während ich
diese hundehütte hier fertig stelle und
zu ende sauber mache möchte ich an der
stelle auf der fertige video star
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
minister watch porsche simulator mit mir
eurem reiniger des vertrauens luca
gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da abonniert main
kanal und klickt auf die glocke wenn ich
das hier werden drei mal weiter spielen
soll wenn ich neue projekte hier
reinigen soll dann schreibt es mir geht
und in die kommentare und was eben auch
mal gerne in die kommentare schreiben
könnte ist was seid ihr für menschen
seit die er so leute die richtig
vorsichtig sind im reinigen oder seid
ihr so komme ich
mache einfach mal ich schlag der zeit wo
damit ihr das hier noch seht
abonnieren
ein kanal
ich glaube ich bin nicht der einzige
youtuber der ein video hochlädt wir
etwas reinigt man halt was wir euch
sowas jeden tag geben muss